Joel Clyde here on the show how are you
Joel I'm great how are you man you seen
some great college football this year
brother dude we've had some amazing
games going back to week one I a it
seems like a lifetime ago but we had the
rosen 34 point comeback Texas USC Penn
State Ohio State last week was a barn
burner for bedlam I think this one might
be the best of them all five versus six
Oklahoma TCU it's gonna be certainly
exciting well you know again you do a
great job Joel as you know I tell you
every time you come on here you do know
the reason why you're seeing all those
great ridiculously tight games correct
you know why right Joel Gus Johnson
discussed affect we had him on he called
in from from Columbus the day before
Penn State Ohio State I'm like what is
it what happened he doesn't want to talk
about it's kind of like Fight Club what
does it like sitting next to him oh gosh
I mean you talk about like pinch
yourself moments can I like let me just
tell you a story about the first year
that we ever got to work with one
another and listen I'm you know I had I
was not a name as a player you know I
had a decent career but I had to really
earn earn my way in this business I
started doing high school football games
and arena football games I've worked
with shoot man 20 30 different
play-by-play guys and producers and so
when I finally got kind of tapped by Fox
to go up and be you know on the lead
crew for college football I was so
excited like a kid in the candy store
and and to boot I get to work with Gus
Johnson right this guy is like kind of
the soundtrack of the NCAA tournament in
my head and just so many great big calls
and so the third game that we ever
called together was Texas hosting Cal
and this was Jared Goff at Cal and
Jerrod Hurd was going to be the
quarterback for Texas and it was an
amazing game now I'm it's it's in
hindsight diminished because of the year
that both of those teams had but this
was early in the season in September and
Jerrod herd took off late in the game to
kind of score what looked like was going
to be a game-tying touchdown and that
was my first time standing next to Gus
when he just like went full Gus
and I gotta tell you here's the best
part he heard takes off and I'm like
here it is you know and so I kind of
turn I'm like I'm gonna watch it and he
turned away from the field to his
spotter our guy
Scotty Scotty's in the booth with him
and Scotty is not just as the spotter he
doubles as the hype man and so all the
sudden like Scotty is like air punching
and he's like going crazy in the booth
and almost dancing around and Gus is
going oh and I was like this is
incredible I came to a game and a
concert broke I love that Joel because
the enthusiasm just jumps through the
screen the both you really really does
it really really does him I appreciate
that seriously and you know I talked
about this with Gus when he was on - it
reminds me of a lot of Stuart Scott when
I sat next to him I would do the same
thing - well we didn't have a hype man
sitting next to him but you know he
would do the same thing doing the
highlights really get into it and it was
just fun to behold and it's infectious
yeah literally it is and people you know
so we've done Oklahoma a couple of times
now in the last three weeks we Adam
against Kansas State and then last week
in bedlam and and Marquis Brown he's a
first-year wide receiver for Oklahoma
and he's a junior college transfer kind
of highly touted he's a small guy so he
didn't get the the recognition that some
other guys did but he is a burner man he
is fast and against Kansas State he's
from Hollywood Florida so against Kansas
State I'm looking down my board and it
says Marquis Brown you know the ball
gets thrown them on my cook heads
Marquis and Gus stars going like
Hollywood like I'm looked back down I
was like wait is this name Hollywood
what's happening and guess what now it
is this guy actually changed his
official name on Twitter to Hollywood
Brown because the Gus Johnson man it's
so great it is great joke lad here on
the show so his Baker Mayfield your
Heisman Trophy guy I mean you've seen
him a lot you've seen him in person what
he can do in big spots joel is he your
Heisman Trophy the front runner yeah and
I think it's by a pretty wide margin
after last week because all the guys
chasing him or or that were in the
conversation had really poor weeks you
know the only one that didn't have
poor week and it was because he got
banged up and left the game early was
Josh Adams
so you don't you know maybe Adam stays
up there due to injury but Bryce loved
had a poor game it was his first game
without a hundred yards of the season
say Quan Barkley again in four of his
last eight halves of football he's
rushed rushed for the negative yards
yeah can't have that as a Heisman
candidate obviously he beats Rudolph
head-to-head we just haven't seen
anybody else step up to the point that
Baker Mayfield has and rich I'm to the
point where I think this guy's going to
have a long NFL career you know coming
into the season I I questioned whether
this RPO style spread system was going
to translate for Baker but this guy is
he's got the leadership intangibles the
efficiency of Russell Wilson and yet
he's got like the magic of Stafford or
Favre in the way that he plays when the
play breaks down and when he loses the
schematics he's one of the best
improvisers that we've got in college
football so my respect level my my
enjoyment of watching him play right now
is that all all-time high so there's a
gonna be a lot going on while you're
what while you're calling TCU in
Oklahoma then you've got Miami and Notre
Dame at the same time essentially under
the lights and so this week we're
finally I do you think we're gonna see a
change in the top four based on this
action win lose between these two teams
that would Oklahoma or TCU crack the top
four with a win should Notre Dame lose
or Miami win in that regard
or should noted everybody wins ahead of
them right so this would I think put
Oklahoma in that top four and maybe even
TCU because they're sitting there at six
kind of primed as well with a great
defense but the thing is I I thought
that the Clemson ahead of Oklahoma this
week last night in the reveal I did not
agree with that
first of all Oklahoma has better wins
their losses is much better than what
Clemson's is and you can deflate or talk
about their defense all you want but the
bottom line is is that this is still a
complimentary game it matters what you
do on the opposite side of your defense
struggles what do you do on the
offensive side is
your offense struggles what do you do on
the defense aside and the fact of the
matter is that Oklahoma right now is
third in the country when it comes to
yards per play margin they're averaging
eight and a half yards per play there
has not been a Power five team that has
done that ever in college football their
defense gives up a lot of yardage but I
rich they play pretty well complementary
you know I mean third in the country
like I said just behind Alabama and
Washington and that margin so I
certainly believe they should have been
four this week with a win they would
absolutely jump into that four because
Clemson does not have much left to build
their resume as they kind of close out
this season well certainly you have to
sit here and think a couple more minutes
left with Joel Clyde of Fox Sports you
have to sit here and think that Georgia
and Alabama are gonna be undefeated when
they see each other in the SEC
championship game and even if there's a
close loss by one of them they're both
in Ryan I mean like you're these are tea
leaves that you can read right now so
there might be just only two non SEC
spots available is that oh well yeah I
know that that's the narrative but I I'm
a big believer that you should have to
win your conference to go play for the
national title okay I thought that last
year I thought Penn State should have
been included
maybe over Ohio State and and I'm gonna
be a big proponent of that this year in
particular let's say Wisconsin is
undefeated they should go over a 1 loss
SEC cuz it's not like this SEC team is
going to be the loser of that game is
going to have gone through some gauntlet
let's say it's Alabama if you actually
put up blindly Alabama in Wisconsin's
resume right next to one another they
are virtually identical it's not like
Alabama has played anybody and the
committee has given them a huge pass by
including LSU in the top 25 and not
Michigan if I was a Michigan fan I'd be
irate two losses on the year and you've
got five three lost teams in the top 25
above the Wolverines you kidding me
that's cooking the books to me rich and
that's up there to support Clemson you
know Clemson's up there with Auburn at
number 10 I don't like that ranking from
Auburn you got LSU up there which
supports Auburn which then supports
Clemson which when which will then
support Alabama so I hear that sentiment
a lot about the loser
of this supposed SEC Championship game
one I don't think that if you lose your
conference you should be able to go to
the playoff and - I just don't think the
resumes of those two teams are all that
strong when you look at just the
disaster that the SEC is this season
great stuff is always Joel send my best
to to Gus and I'll definitely want to
speak to you before you go back to the
big house in a couple weeks gonna be my
first visit rich I'm like I can't even
tell you how excited I am I've never
called a game in the big house we're
gonna be there for the Ohio State game
I'll have them next week as well when
they travel up to a Camp Randall and
face Wisconsin look forward to that Joel
really really will thanks again you got
a Jesse bud gun that's a Joel Klein on
Twitter for more Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Rich Eisen show app